Hello,
I'm Zainab.
Welcome Susie,
magnificent concert hall here in
Stockholm where this year's Nobel prize
winners received their awards from the
king of Sweden.
This is the first time that they have
come together on television and they're
joined him in the audience by their
family and friends as well as students
from all over Sweden.
We'll be asking them if the best kinds
of science is useful.
Science.
Welcome to Nobel minds and this year we
have discoveries that help with our
everyday lives that bring light to
poorer communities and reduce energy
costs that tell us how we know where we
are and where we're going.
The chemistry prize is about seeing now
for the first time we have microscopes
that can see molecules and the economics
prize helps tell us how we can better
structure markets to benefit the
consumer and society.
So that's the work of our Nobel
laureates here.
Congratulations and welcome to you all.
Thank you.
So before we talk about your various
activities and so on,
I want to know how you all found out
that you had become this year's Nobel
prize winners and it is wonderful to
have a rare species with us today,
a female scientists who has won the
Nobel prize.
You want to medicine or physiology my
bridge from Norway.
So just tell us how did you
find out?
It was a bit for Monday morning and we
had a discussion presentation of some
data and uh,
I was so excited by these data and then
I got this annoying phone call and it
was a,
a number that I didn't recognize and I
just know I normally don't answer the
phone stuff that I don't know the
number.
And then I suddenly got this female
intuition behave.
I'm sort of formed.
Your reaction went viral when that,
when you realize why you'd won.
You don't sing,
didn't you?
My Brett,
can you show us
one time?
No,
we have the Nobel prize laureates here
who danced for joy when she heard she
got it.
EADWEARD.
Muybridge is your wife a couple of both
them.
And also your,
your colleague,
Professor John O'keefe,
who is not with us,
you were given the prize in medicine or
physiology,
but you were on an airplane.
I understand.
Okay.
Right.
So I actually got to know it after
everyone else.
I landed at Munich airport.
I was going to institute and then uh,
I was met by a woman and a
representative from the airports that
picked me up and I asked why does you
come to the gate of the plane?
And she told me that,
uh,
I won the price,
I didn't take it.
And then she said it was a plank for a
price for the,
from the Max Planck Society.
So she mixed it up.
And then finally I started checking my
phone and then hundreds of messages.
And then one from urine.
Hanson,
he.
No,
no,
she was not there yet.
And he said that it's important.
Call me back and then I.
So that's how you found out.
Okay.
And I'm Stefan.
Hell,
so you were,
um,
I think you were accessible,
weren't you?
Yes,
actually I had a project discussion with
the postdoc because we have seen
something new and exciting with our
sharp light microscope.
You will want as a chemist Laurie,
as I say.
Yeah,
right.
And actually I wanted to know whether
this has been seen somewhere else and,
and put down the paper where I felt that
it could be perhaps mentioned there or
not and I want to start at the paper to
see what it was known on,
if that is totally new,
what we've seen.
And it turned out to be new.
So.
And the phone rang,
the phone rang and I was surprised of
what's going on in towns chemists
laureates here,
Eric Betzig.
Um,
I think you will also see conference in
Germany.
I was find out.
Well,
I think there's somebody here who can
speak to that question better than I
really?
Yes.
Will be my son.
Ravi is 15 years old.
So where's Ruthie?
You've got to it.
So.
Hello everybody,
this is Ravi.
I'm bad sex.
So what happened?
So,
uh,
keep in mind that unlike the others,
my father and I live in the states.
So the announcement is very,
very early in the morning,
our time,
5:30
AM night woken up early to do some work
and the phone rings.
I'm thinking who on earth is calling
this early in the morning,
but I pick it up and they say it's a
secretary and I say hello.
And she says yes as Dr [inaudible] and I
say yes ma'am.
I'm Dr Betsy.
She's a little bit skeptical,
but um,
she transfers the line to our in oldest
running man.
He says,
sorry,
Dr Betsy.
Congratulations on winning the Nobel
prize in Chemistry along with your
colleague Stefan Helen Wu Warner.
And I said Sir sir.
Yes,
I'm,
I'm actually not Dr Ben.
Dr Ben is my father currently on
business and Germany.
And here's his mobile number if you want
to comment
question for you.
What were you doing?
Wake up 5:30
in the morning school.
What I wanted to finish.
Right.
Okay.
That explains it.
Well,
thank you very much.
So that's how you found out then they
called you on your mobile phone,
but,
but you can see I have a prize.
It's much more valuable than a.
no,
absolutely,
absolutely.
One of your four children I think.
Is that right?
Yeah.
And I'm professor Wu wwii murder.
So what were you up to?
I was in Brazil.
I had a conference conferences,
scientific conference,
getting dressed ready to go to the
meeting.
And the first thing that happened was a
text from my wife.
It says,
turn on your phone.
Of course my phone didn't really work
there.
So anyway,
she had gotten contacted first by the
Associated Press and called me.
So you knew it wasn't a prank call.
Okay.
So two of the three Nobel Prize winners
in physics because your,
your colleague,
professor,
Achan Psyche again is not with us
professor Nakamura.
So I think you live in California
because you're at University of Santa
Barbara,
so it must have been an earthly our for
you when you were told.
Yeah.
So basically I,
you know,
I got the phone call out CPM,
so it's.
So it's him as I was sleeping and also I
am the but the sub one day before I know
my is totally to me and know you have to
put the cell phone.
Maybe dad possibility.
No.
Yeah,
I left my cell phone next to my bed and
the answer to this,
what kind of for war and so it wasn't a
huge surprise for you.
What about your colleagues here?
Professor Ammonia?
Yeah.
It might get worse in praying from.
Not Weird in Japan to try and get on the
ice.
So many,
many email title.
The congratulations from graduation
going to.
I didn't understand why to the
conversation.
So I moved to the final destination to
Leon and found many journalists came the
exit of the whole farm.
Find that our funding.
So you actually Leon in France where you
found out.
So that's it.
And professors on zero.
You are the um,
so winner of the Nobel Prize in
economics this year.
Now I think you'd miss the initial
coordinate because your phone was on
vibrate.
Were you working on some great new
theory?
Did Not.
I was,
I was working on the European Research
Council grant or is it kind of already.
We also have to get money.
Every scientist and like my vibrator,
I didn't want to be bothered so I put my
phone on vibrate.
So they kept calling and calling and
calling and then I have funny or the
phone vibrating and I looked at it at a
45,
six,
46,
46.
Is Sweden what's going on?
So I took it and you're getting then you
wonder,
is that a joke?
And you know,
it was not a joke because you're here
now let's carry on with you professor
too,
because um,
you would given the Nobel prize
basically for various theories that all
come under one umbrella as it were,
of how to structure markets,
regulate,
regulate big business and so on,
to better benefit the consumer.
And I know that um,
when you were giving your ceremony,
I was listening to the citation,
they sort of compared your theories to a
baker,
how I'm a baker,
a selling bad bread and has no
competition is going to carry on selling
the bad bread rather extensively.
And your theory helps set us how we can
tackle that kind of market abuse.
Oh,
that's why it's free.
There's always dance shows at firms with
child noncompetitive can raise price or
offer low quality.
So you have to work through it in two
different ways.
One is onto trust or competition policy.
You intervene to avoid abuses of domain
and position on that nurtures which will
raise the price and lower quantity.
Oh,
you're kind of regulate directly today
comes and the electricity in banks and
the likes.
So our work has been to,
uh,
apply Game Theory and information
economics to that kind of situation,
so as to provide series and unpack all
the work that could lpars those
authorities to deal with big firms.
Can you see now,
um,
areas where we have monopolies or only
got police where they are kind of
crowding out competition and they
themselves perhaps or a bit inefficient
and give expensive products for the
consumer.
Could you think that's quite a common
problem in the world now?
It's a common probably.
It has always been.
I mean we're still,
today comes connectricity on railroads
are what we call essential facilities or
bottlenecks which are extremely costly
to reproduce.
So you have not shown monopolies and
you,
you have to give access to create
competition.
So part of our work was to think about
how to create the access to those
bottlenecks,
but you also have,
um,
you know,
an old high tech industries you like,
you have like Google and Microsoft and
are large fixed costs,
for example,
building a search engine that allows
network side is because there are lots
of apps and people want to inter operate
and so in the end you tend to have
monopolies at some point of time,
but the important thing is that a new
firms which are more efficient can enter
to replace those monopolies if needed.
I want to go to the audience here
because we've got a couple of questions.
Economic students.
Um,
we have one here.
Just say your name briefly and then put
your question please.
Maria.
Um,
when did you ask what do you think it is
more effective to regulate large
entities like Spain or the United
Kingdom or maybe smaller ones like
Catalonia and Scotland.
Okay.
Before you answer that,
let's just see if there's any other
question.
Yup.
Young lady behind you.
Just give us your name.
My name is.
You authored that you work.
Doesn't have to be influenced by your
political ideas,
but as economics and politics are
quietly related,
what are your recommendations for future
economies to remain as much as possible?
Politically neutral.
Okay.
Do you want to answer that first of all,
is it easier?
Is Regulation easier when it's for
cause?
I mean that's it,
you know,
you can't just regulate parts of the
financial institutions.
Globalization means you need a global
regular.
Yes.
Question is a very important one for one
thing.
Lots of those firms now like bang socks,
she multinationals.
So we have to regulate at a broader
level.
So in Europe for example,
the banking union which tries to
actually regulate at the ECB level of
the European Central Bank level and the
antitrust authorities also tried to
cooperate more,
more and more with each other because
it's hard,
you know,
Google is a worldwide enterprise of
course.
Um,
so that's uh,
that's a,
that's only point in saying and you
know,
climate change also ease of use thing
that you have to regulate that the,
at the world level regulated at the
country level is not going to lie
because then the pollution is going to
migrate somewhere else.
So you need a world agreement for that.
Again,
in your citation they said that um,
you don't shy away from the politics and
I know that you've been quoted in the
press gave me advice to the French
government about its massive deficit and
telling them that they have to reform or
die and so on.
So you don't shirk the political area,
do you?
Well,
I tried to be neutral in the sand that
I'm never comment on 40 titian and
politics or you know,
support a candidate or anything like
that.
I think it's very important because
otherwise you are linked to a party or
to some ideas and,
and basically discredited because they
will say you,
you are saying that not because of your
science because it has those particular
leaning.
So actually when I got to price also
John,
I wanted to know whether for Walmart,
40th and nobody was able to say and also
they wanted to know whether I was a
provocateur and the Thai market person
and they weren't able to send.
And the reason is that I just say what
my son says and you know,
was I like it or not,
I just go for it and you know,
and then Jonah is didn't extrapolate.
Of course,
you know,
they're,
they're saying,
you know,
they try to decide soon in support of
this color of this person or this part
in and that I disliked political
kind of unbiased and you stick to your
science,
but you do have very strong political
opinions.
For instance,
you've been quoted as saying that you
think the euro is a flawed currency and
do you believe in what could loosely be
described as a EU?
EU superstate your big federalist?
I'm a big fit out is.
Yes,
that's right.
I mean do you always on institutions how
little bit weak.
So it's a currency union,
but at the same time you don't have the
institution which goes through is a
currency union like the US for example,
or us as a currency union but also as a
common budget has common lowe's and we
don't have that in Europe and I would
like to have that in Europe as well.
Now it's a bit difficult to do right now
because there's such a difference
between a northern Europe and south
Europe.
That's,
we should have done that earlier of
course.
But hopefully that will.
But you say you're a big federal.
It is,
but I mean,
you know,
you look around European countries at
the moment and you know,
you in the phone nasional in France did
very well with the parliamentary
elections.
We have the UK Independence Party in the
United Kingdom.
Uh,
your,
your opinions perhaps a slightly going
against the tide of public opinion in
Europe,
right?
I'm afraid.
So I mean,
it's true that Jemena in Sweden,
you see what's happening and it's
happening almost in every country in
Europe where you rehab the casino for
big countries and the parties and it's
very hard to understand them and we
should,
it,
we should understand the word story is
leading you a is leading us and people
just don't fly on.
And also that very bad economics and all
of those parties,
those extremist parties,
I've terrible economics,
but people don't realize that.
Edward,
let's turn to what you did.
You did.
It was divided into two,
the price between your work and
professor o'keeffe's.
And um,
since he's not here,
just to sort of paraphrase that he
identified what are known as place cells
working with rats,
which kind of tells us about the
workings of the inner gps in our brains
that tell us how we know where we are
and where we're going and how we store
that information so we can use it for
the next time.
Yeah.
So tell us,
tell us more about why his discovery was
so significant.
You muybridge,
you listen to the small electrical
pulses in the brain and the brain says,
because they talk about sending
electrical pulses and one such a pulse,
you can magnify a soda,
it's a 10,000,
20,000
a more in amplitude and then you can
listen to it and then a place that would
be silence,
silence,
pop,
and whenever the rat is coming back to
certain place in the environment,
you had the same popcaan sound like a
popcorn bag in the microwave oven and
it's such a beautiful sound for us and
we've got about half a million to a
million place cells in our brains in the
hippocampus at least,
which is somewhere near the temples.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Just somewhere that you identified a
separate set of nerve cells involved in
navigation which are activated when Irak
passes certain locations.
Hence the grid cells.
So just you tell us about those.
Yeah,
so the difference is that the place of
subtle Keith discovered they are usually
active at one location.
The sales,
what we discovered,
we call them grid cells because they are
active at many locations.
And those many locations form agreed
very,
very periodic map or the environment.
So it's almost like a coordinate system
a while you have points that
are at regular distances.
Sure.
And since we're talking about useful
science,
this discovery,
helping us understand how the brain
works,
but do we know illnesses like brain
diseases like Alzheimer's,
that sense of space and where you're
going is one of the first things to go.
So what kind of application might your
discovery health,
Alzheimer's and other mental.
Yeah,
I would like to see two things about
that.
First of all,
a dot area that contains those cells,
that's usually the first one to be
affected in Alzheimer's disease and you
get a problems with a navigation and so
on.
But so it's very important for
Alzheimer,
but it also say that it's perhaps even
more important because it allows us to
understand the basic principles of how
the brain works.
So these cells are so easy to measure.
It's actually provided a window into the
working principles of the brain.
And I think this is basic research.
We understand how the brain works and
then in the future I can go and t will
also understand other diseases because
we get to the fundamental principles of
the brain,
like what are the diseases,
schizophrenia,
depression,
anxiety disorders,
the whole spectrum because they all
depend on,
on some,
uh,
a rather small number of the working
principles that is used by the brain.
Wonderful.
Let's say that sauce.
Yes.
And,
and,
and the interesting thing is,
well then resend to hear that if you
have a window and you can put the
window,
just remove part of the skull and put
the window and use these guys.
Microscopes,
I'm just,
we'll come to these guys microscopes and
go to the audience who's got a question
for the most,
is this dynamic duo.
Obviously the two of you working
together and was very successful,
but maybe you can tell us a little bit
more.
How is it if your partner,
your colleague at work is at the same
time,
your wife or husband infused seed or
each other?
All the time?
I can tell you one thing at least I
don't have to sit home and then get the
critics.
Why isn't a dinner
finished my bread?
You are,
as I said,
a rare species because there are very
few women at this table sign with
scientists.
I will use more exact scientific,
precise language.
You are the only female amongst these
Nobel laureates.
That's true and I often sit around this
table when I've done this program in the
false and they're a new female science
laureate,
so I have to ask you,
why is it that you know,
particularly at the top of the pyramid
in the scientific community and academic
institutions,
there are very few.
My brother even in your own country,
Norway.
No,
that's not part of my background in
science,
so I have to just pick it up and of
course when,
when when you need to.
When when you get such a price,
you are sort of top of a pyramid and in
order to come to that pyramid you need a
pool and the pool you need is a lot of
women here and then it's become sharper
and sharper up to the top.
So it's just about we need to get more
women interested and also more women who
can trust themselves so that I think I'm
good enough to win the Nobel prize.
Why not?
But uh,
to,
to be in science,
you have to work a lot,
you have to travel a lot and especially
a mom and here is unlike their bias,
but especially a mom who doesn't want to
leave the chamber conferences when and
girls were very small and,
and leaving a baby while you are
breastfeeding.
You don't do that.
It's,
it's,
it's painful.
I've tried it once and never ever again.
Any other comments from here,
Eric,
but thick.
My wife and I,
uh,
met at Janelia.
She's a neuroscientist.
And same thing is,
is that it's a two heads or even though
she's in a different field than I am,
you know,
two heads are better than one.
There's sort of common principles that
we can help each other out at work and
we can help with the child rearing and
tag team take off,
you know,
time is necessary for the kids.
But one thing we don't do is no pillow
talk about science.
Once we get home,
sciences will tell us where the rubbish
out and that kind of conversation.
We want a stress free environment.
And Professor Mona your views on this.
Well,
what I see happening is some
improvements in these numbers over time.
I bet if you looked at those numbers 10
years ago,
you see that there are better now
because some of these new policies that
are being put in place to help with
child rearing that or help with sort of
alternative ways of,
of helping across this barrier.
So we're working hard on it.
We're,
we're working very hard to get more
women in at high levels of the professor
at,
in the United States.
I think.
Cool.
Definitely in Germany,
I think the number of female students in
physics and chemistry has gone up
substantially.
So when I started out of 100 students,
we have maybe two or three little women.
Now it's 20.
Your Chancellor Angela Merkel is a
scientist?
Yes.
Excellent.
Is wonderful module there.
Yes.
And she works.
She's a scientist too,
didn't she?
She didn't just study it.
Yes.
That's great.
What about the experience in Japan,
women scientists in Japan,
how do they do
in terms of the statistics?
Well,
we are doing.
The development are only 80 percent.
Eight percent of the women in my
university.
He know where you're immersed.
You are per se so.
Well one of the top level university,
but still
eight percent women.
Natural Universe where you will.
Yeah.
Thank.
So let's
turn to the chemist laureate.
So you basically working independently
came up with a solution to make
microscopes work much better so that now
for the first time we can look inside
cells to see molecules,
but how did you do that?
Because I mean microscopes had been
around for ages.
The prize recognizes super resolution
fluorescence microscopy and some people
might not know what this fluorescents
business areas so I can illustrate it a
little bit and give you a few of the key
ideas here.
Here's a liquid.
There are a lot of molecules in this
vial,
maybe 10 to the 24th.
That's one with 24 Zeros after it,
but inside this we also have some
fluorescent molecules that and we want
to be able to see these molecules.
So let me just illustrate the idea.
I have a green laser here,
a green laser pointer that's a green,
very green,
but when I shine it through this
solution,
the fluorescent molecules inside give
you a more of a yellowish color and you
can see that I can just like a light
saber only where the beam is going.
It's hitting the molecules and the
molecules are sending light back.
That's what we mean by fluorescents.
And so what we are doing,
and these microscopes is using lasers
and this property I just showed that the
molecules themselves,
he meant like bags,
like little tiny light sources and it's
because 25 years ago one of the ways to
achieve super resolution relies on being
able to see single molecules.
That's what I worked on.
And you can actually now with your eyes,
look into a microscope and see the light
coming from individual molecules.
So Eric,
I mean the,
the,
the chemistry prize was awarded because
it's about seeing.
But what is this seeing actually do.
What kind of diseases might it help is I
always feel uncomfortable when media
tries to project us into technologies.
It will have applications,
but it's very difficult to predict.
That's one of the things with technology
in general is it's very difficult to
predict what the ultimate ultimate
benefits will be.
And you're willing to predict he's
winning.
Question to ask.
I mean we have used the high resolution
in order to find out key processes going
on.
For example,
in HIV.
So biology,
I'm quite quite confident,
will be strongly impacted by the
microscopes that we have invented,
professor managing feel queasy about
answering what kind of future
applications.
Well,
the real point is you see in much
greater detail than what you saw before
and you see surprises,
you see things that weren't necessarily
expected and all of these super
resolution methods or something like
recognizing that the cell is something
like a little city where there are many
molecules,
proteins that are moving around a little
motors and DNA and RNA and so forth.
But if you only look at it very,
very high up in the sky where it's only
fuzzy,
you don't see what's going on,
super resolution lets you see far more
clearly that is a factor five,
10 or more better already.
And the point is then you see surprises.
Things that we didn't understand about
the cell biology.
You've benefited from these guys.
Discovery something
general.
Yes.
The advances in microscopy and
especially the advances that allow
microscopes,
fluorescence microscopes to be used in,
uh,
in living animals.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the resolution that the three lawyers
have worked on today,
it's even beyond what we can use at the
moment,
but I think this will come.
Professors,
Mr.
No.
And I'm professor of Nakamura along with
professor I Kosaki you were awarded the
Nobel Prize in Physics for your blue
light emitting diode,
which made possible a highly efficient
light source that's now replacing the
incandescent light bulb that Thomas
Edison gave us.
So we've had red,
green emitting diodes.
For what?
About 50 years in your blue?
One has been around for about 20 years.
You combine the blue with the red and
the green and perhaps you can show us
what happens professor knocking.
Laura.
Yeah,
a biscuit.
We thought a brewer,
you cannot make quite big.
The is of the led lighting.
Is that a point to point?
Right source.
So we can't use dance to make any kind
of shape of light.
For example,
this is a site coordinator,
but he puts some kind of feed into it to
be from.
They found gonna ship.
This is the best,
a right to enforce the act art,
you know,
so this kind of lights is amazing
because it's brought a,
the potential of a cheap source of
energy for communities all over the
world that don't have access tonight.
And it's also bringing down energy
bills.
Yes.
Because it's a more efficient use of
yes,
at this is can't be opened by buttery
mobile cell phone,
ipad or kind of mobile device.
Have to use this thing to make these
sprays.
And also most important.
Is that a southern country?
So the country?
Yeah.
No electricity,
only energy source.
Like a Sunday night,
just sort of say and sort of our charge
the battery,
daytime and nighttime edited it.
So you have solar power,
this kind of device and a battery with
the blue led giving the,
the white light and it's how much would
that cost as a device?
I see now
$10.
Yeah.
So a person could use that $10 with the
source of solar power.
And how long would that last for three
years.
Three years?
Yes.
Yeah.
Especially in Japan.
Electricity generation.
Maybe you remember that day in 2011,
they had the big earthquake in Japan,
so the above the old nuclear power print
stuff now,
so the new group or a presence,
a bride,
the 30 percent of director issue,
but now it all stopped so we have to
adapt another way.
So the led is very important to reduce
energy consumption.
The they enable price.
It is that electricity lighting accounts
for about 20 percent of global energy
use through the use of your white led in
time.
That could come down to five percent.
Not only do these light bulbs last 100
times as long as the incandescent bulb,
they also contain no mercury and one
application also is the ultra violet
light can be used to clean polluted
water.
Yes,
a buyer a day to use folk are basically
to kill bacteria,
are able to bias a bias by that virus
and also to a pure water.
And the Po Po buyers are basically you
can't you,
you read it back bucket you.
It's amazing.
It killed bacteria.
Purify light on,
but professor like a Marie,
you had a very publicized fight with the
corporation that was funding your
research.
You felt that your,
you weren't properly remunerated for the
research that you did to develop the
blue led,
you would give them what?
A bonus of $180 and they went to and you
could potentially make millions and
millions out of this invention.
Yes.
This guy,
he's says,
I moved to the United States and my full
comm company started the lawsuit against
using got infringement over 30 to
secret.
So I became so angry about,
to my,
uh,
to my former company.
So as a counter lawsuit I started that.
A lawsuit I guess in my former company
using the Japanese pop into roll out
through South Dakota is even if I could
do embed for company as an employee,
potential rights belong to me.
So the patient rights in Japan belonged
to the inventor,
the company that employs the inventor.
That was lucky for you
if I have any.
I really meant it all.
So it measures so but the but quote and
I quote,
the judge says,
you know,
how the incidents to be drawn to the
company if the agreement over the
document but the judge also same damn
fool
with me.
You have a right to get that.
These are not brutal compensation fee.
I wouldn't say what it is,
but he was very reasonable.
Wasn't happy with it.
Yeah.
It made you a millionaire.
I'm not talking about $8 million
dollars.
Not Bad at all.
I mean,
how do you feel around the table here
that in terms of,
you know,
intellectual property and patent rights
and whether your inventions all used in
the future in a way which is basically a
money spinner.
Do you feel that you should.
We have a number of paths for our stuff?
Uh,
most of them are infringed on left and
right.
And frankly we don't care.
You know,
I mean,
you can either spend your time talking
to lawyers all the time and be miserable
or you can get back in the lab and
invent something else that you looked to
your fault tool company.
I mean,
would he not have appreciated it if you
invented?
Well,
I didn't invent things for his company
that just sold poor stuff on my kids.
Very unusual.
I started out in my scientific career is
writing a patent in 1990 before I had a
postdoctoral job and this turned out to
be extremely helpful because at the
latest stage in my career,
um,
I run out of support,
institutional support and so I use this
patent and basically licensed it to a
small company in Finland that gave me
money,
hundred thousand dollars in return and
they use this money in a very critical
period to do my research.
And that nine months of research that
was funded by,
by $100,000
really got me that.
Glad to hear that.
That was very forced.
So your patient patients can be
absolutely lifesaving.
Yes.
What about,
what about here where you can't really
patient?
Yours is just the knowledge isn't
anybody trust?
What about youtube?
I think for us,
simple to say that neuroscience is a big
family and we share a lot of both ids
and a data.
So from our lab,
we put data on the Internet so that
other people can analyze it and the two
reasons.
One is that we give very good data and
the second thing is then we don't need
that money anonymous since when did the
animal research?
So we've got a question from the
audience.
My question relates to research in
Africa.
We know that huge successes have been
made in the West and uh,
in my opinion is a lack of collaboration
with researchers in Africa.
We just resorted to the outbreak of
Ebola for example.
How could this be explained and what was
this push to?
Global health.
Okay,
thank you.
We'll take another question from the
floor
and my question was a little bit related
to question is,
are experimental science because high is
our main tool.
How do you identify that's power kill
that will turn into a fire because so
many time lens on
something and then because they don't
have enough elements to pack it up,
sometime that tends to just it on the
side,
but how do you,
what does it get to get the level of
price?
How do we identify it?
Oh,
well,
all right,
Eric Betzig a few points there.
Um,
you know,
because I have opinions on all of them
but I don't want to just touch on it.
But you're a very interesting story
because here you are a Nobel laureate in
chemistry.
But I think in your own words you said I
was lousy at chemistry.
I sucked at chemistry.
That was my exact.
And in fact none of you is a chemist and
yeah,
well yeah,
you all,
sorry.
Famous your department physical
chemistry but your physicist and do your
more like physicists.
But anyway,
with that,
uh,
but uh,
the committee cited to specific papers
for me to get the prize and both of them
happy while I was unemployed.
So,
um,
but,
but the,
in terms of the spark thing,
I think what,
what you want to do is you want to
immerse yourself in problems and try to
not sweep problems under the rug,
but focus on problems and outstanding
problems and try to put pieces of a
puzzle together to solve these.
And if a good scientist I think gets
this monomaniacal focus on the problem
and you may not have all of the
problems,
but at least in my case,
the solutions have come when I'm not
directly looking at the problem,
but through the subconscious mind,
either I was pushing my daughter around
in a stroller or so poincare talks about
this in his book about how you have to
just starve your mind of everything
except the problem.
So the subconscious is forced to work on
it.
And then he was taking a vacation,
stepping on a bus and then all of a
sudden he had this flash of insight.
It's,
it's kind of for me,
I have great confidence in my
subconscious mind.
I've described you as a counter reaction
to chemist and how you,
you're not good at chemistry at school,
but you also had a bit of a kind of
disdain for academia and you know,
life in the ivory tower and if fact you
quit academia research and went to work
for your family's tool business.
Right?
So,
so I,
I still don't think I would ever be
comfortable in a standard academic
environment in some ways.
Um,
I've always just wanted to work at the
bench and in some ways the standard
model seems to me an incredibly
inefficient way to do research because
you train somebody to excel at bench
science through their postdoc and then
you make an assistant professor out of
them and rip that all away from them and
stick them in an office and make an
administrator out of them.
I've been fortunate both at Bell Labs
and then where I work now,
they believe in,
in allowing scientists be scientists and
not administrators and,
and people begging for grants and so I
can be in the lab and be more
productive.
Stefan.
Yeah.
We also had a question about,
um,
you know,
for instance,
other viruses
and so on and we're told all the time
now the antibiotics and not as effective
as they used to be.
Does your work in any way relate?
How would you answer that question?
The context of your work?
Because before you can cure something,
you have to understand.
Exactly,
exactly.
And I think microscopes allow us better
to understand what's going on including
the disease cell and of course,
I think to some extent below to allow to
send much better how drugs work.
And um,
um,
I can imagine that,
uh,
seeing things now at a cellular level
will affect treating diseases
substantially.
So in conclusion,
Olivia,
do you think that the best science is
useful science and all these putting
Nobel laureates we have around.
What is your final word of advice to
anyone?
I want to get back
to the question or basic science.
I really think it's so important that we
also spend efforts around understanding
things where we don't know what it will
be useful for because the,
in this specialty perhaps we'll see that
in neuroscience.
I mean,
you understand,
you don't understand the brain enough to
know actually what is useful.
But,
uh,
I think as we get more knowledge about
how the brain works,
I know that it will be important for,
for the whole range of psychiatry,
neurology and so on
and for us professional.
But there's,
there's many ways in which these two
ideas are intermingled.
A.
Absolutely.
I agree that basic science is very
important,
but sometimes basic science can be
driven by some technological need and
there's many examples of where the
technology has an has something new that
needs to be invented and that sort of
gets people's mind thinking,
uh,
I can come up with an idea that might
make that work and then new science
comes out of the ability of that new
method to see new things,
the original single molecule where it
came from,
work at IBM on exploring an optical
storage scheme and the fundamental
limits of a completely different optical
storage game completely out in left
field and,
and we,
we saw a single molecules as a result
and then that blossomed into
applications.
In biology.
It's,
you just have to have both,
but you have to have some interplay
between them and stable,
continued funding for the basic science.
What about your advice to budding Nobel
scientists and economists because you're
a real superstar now in France.
Wherever you go,
you're stopped,
you know,
photographs and resident and we know the
Prime Minister Manuel Val said that this
was a poke in the eye.
All these people who were being emptied,
French gallic passionate and so are you
happy being a French area?
It's trey nice to.
I mean,
there's a lot of pride in my country
about this,
uh,
you know,
the concert in my honor,
if I turned on so qwiff and then there
was a big banner on the Cto of my city,
12 meter by 15.
Wow.
The CTO for two weeks and I got stopped
me in the street,
but in the end,
you know,
it's flattering,
but this guy wants to do is to go back
to my lab and the Japanese and the
Japanese media have been really huge in
that.
Presidents don't comb with three
Japanese Nobel laureates.
I mean your superstars on the Uw
Professor Nakamura,
I mean you said you know,
your battle with the Japanese
corporation.
You'd left in disgust and went to the
United States because you felt that you
could develop your work better there.
But how'd you feel holding two
directions?
Japan is claiming you was that great.
One of the great stars.
Yeah.
He,
I don't know,
but I'd be getting bored in Japan.
So that's that.
As I moved to the United States to
challenge a new scenes waterways as a
scientist,
I have to do new things,
new talent,
so that,
that is.
I moved to the United States and about
the,
the um,
but that,
um,
that now I'm a US citizen.
I have my us citizenship stuff.
They'll find definitely people find
their might use this or they become
angry.
Noble Nordic for United States.
Japan.
What'd you think about what your just
said that the United States,
they're right by law.
I have a rate of a different opinion.
You might get it.
It's like an engineering science and
know for instance,
you might find the most important thing
is to imagine the future system or
imagined the future for,
for example,
the Microsoft Bill Gates.
Like,
so what would the itch like an inpatient
oriented.
Of course I understand that a
fundamental basic study,
the very important,
but for us the most important thing,
so basic studies to freaking direction
should we go.
So stuff on him.
I think it's best to concentrate on
problems that seem to be very difficult
to solve.
Um,
I think those problems are the most
interesting problems,
the most rewarding problems,
but there's,
of course there's risk in taking a,
tackling such problems.
So therefore I think we have to embrace
not only taking risks,
but also we have to embrace the
failures,
especially also to honor those people
who try heart,
do their best but fail,
but don't start with this is a problem
in the world.
I want to fix it.
Um,
that may be like that,
but sometimes you get an idea of what
you want to do and that comes out of the
blue.
And I'm with intuition of course.
And usually if you,
if you do it out of intuition,
intuition is passion.
And yet you have to be passionate about
what you do.
No,
it is about passion.
And you need a vision so you,
you,
you want to have a burning question.
And if you have a burning question,
whatever it's microscopes are leds or
economy or neuroscience,
then that is to start at,
is leading you forward.
And then you don't care about methods or
if you have a salary or whatever you
have because it's so burning.
You can't stop a passion or an
obsession.
Obsession.
Also,
your psychologist,
you should know all about sessions and
so on.
Eric Betzig,
what would your advice
to the potential?
No,
we're just been said passion.
Um,
but a lot of times I see kids in high
school or college who are in science who
are in some ways pushed in a science
and,
and sometimes their motivations are to
please their parents or something else.
And if you would rather be a rap star or
rather be a painter or rather be
something else,
just follow your passion because in the
end the purpose of the passion is get
you past the failures and to get you so
that you work hard.
Because every field of endeavor it comes
down in the end to hard work and hard
work is kind of like compound interest
in a bank.
If you work 10 percent harder than the
other guy,
it actually multiplies year-by-year
until all of a sudden your experiences
twice or triple the other guy.
And then you can excel in your field and
then you win a Nobel prize.
Well,
who cares about that?
So thank you.
You heard it here,
folks.
Passion.
I'm all for passion.
That's the end of this exclusive program
with this year's Nobel laureates.
We've looked into the minds of some of
the greatest brains working currently in
their fields.
That's all from the concert hall here in
Stockholm.
Thank you to our audience here,
family and friends of the laureates,
as well as students from all over
Sweden.
Thank you to you wherever you are
watching this for me.
Zainab Badawi.
Goodbye.